[Music]
hi hello everyone my name is Karen miner
and welcome to the table or as I like to
call it the table quarantine community
if you're here you are officially a part
of it and I'm excited because this is my
first time doing participating in one of
our online services and I have to admit
I'm nervous all of this technology stuff
is new to me and I'm used to looking at
faces and seeing eyes and smiles and all
of that but I am really happy that I
have a reason to wear something besides
PJs and sweatshirts and I'm really glad
to be with you all as people are joining
us online I want to take a moment to
share a couple of announcements with you
so make sure you're joining in you're
commenting down below let us know that
you're here so we can say hello and
welcome you we just want everybody to
feel like they're a part of this table
family so as far as announcements go as
you know we're entering into Easter week
and so we have two opportunities to be
together virtually as a community as we
head into Easter
the first one is Good Friday this coming
Friday we're going to be live-streaming
at 7:00 p.m. on Facebook and YouTube and
I'm really looking forward to doing a
the joint service that we're going to be
having with our friends at Pleasant
Valley United Methodist Church that's
the church that we rent the building
from we've become really good friends
with them you love their community and
I'm really looking forward to joining
them in a reflective more subdued
service that will include Scripture and
song and prayer from the table community
as well as Pleasant Valley so please
plan to join us for that Friday night
7:00 p.m. and then of course we have
Easter Sunday that will be at our usual
time 5:00 p.m. so one week from today 5
p.m. right here on Facebook live and
also on YouTube
I was just realizing that this is going
to be our very first table Easter and
although it's a lot different than how
we originally envisioned it it is an
opportunity for us to join together and
remember the hope that we have in Christ
and to celebrate that to celebrate God's
goodness so I hope you'll join us for
that as well so before we get started
into worship which we're in for a treat
because Joe and Josh Brock are leading
us tonight I thought just with
everything going on in our world and I
don't know what your days been like if
it's been a lot of activity moving
around or more just sitting around
whatever it's been I thought it would be
good for us together to just quiet
ourselves quiet are thinking minds quiet
our thoughts our worries just that
internal dialogue that can often take
over without us realizing so just want
to invite you to close your eyes quiet
your mind unclench your jaw unfurl your
brow relax your body take a deep breath
in and out once again in and out allow
yourself to relax allow yourself to be
here now allow yourself to just
surrender any anxious thoughts any
worries any to dues that are on your
mind for later use this time to let that
go and be here now God we thank you that
we can be together in this way again
we thank you for your presence that is
always with us and guide we sent her on
you and we give this time to you your
[Music]
father
[Applause]
[Music]
my Jesus I'm gonna read from Romans 8
verse 37 through 39 but in all these
things we overwhelmingly conquer through
him who loves us so now I live with
confidence that there is nothing in the
universe but the power to separate us
from God's love not trouble not hard
times not hatred not hunger not
homelessness not bullying threats not
backstabbing and not even a pandemic
absolutely nothing can get between us
[Music]
[Applause]
father thank you for this time and I
pray that we can take this loving energy
that you have bestowed upon us here on
earth we can take it out into the world
despite the quarantine we find ourselves
in
thank you for this community of
believers ah hello hello grace and peace
welcome and a huge thank you to Josh and
Joe for leading us so beautifully um
they have really good chemistry and
thank you to Karen as well I was so glad
to have her kind of able to jump in this
week and it's really really good to be
with all of you obviously I would love
to be in person um but I guess this is
like the next best thing and so I'm yeah
I'm glad that we can connect in this way
so I'm really glad you could join us
this evening so we are in this is now
part five of our series titled
tranquility cultivating calm in a crazy
world and it's really it's all about
empowering all of us with like insights
with tools really just to be able to do
that well to cultivate that kind of
tranquility and calm because we really
want to be a church who not only
worships Jesus who not only says like
Jesus is Lord but but who actually um
endeavors to live the way he lists and
of course we're in a really challenging
time right now due to the virus and for
many of us it's challenging really for a
variety of reasons um it could be
work-related right we could just be
stressed out by either works gone crazy
and we're trying now to like do it from
home and that's frustrating and
stressful or it's maybe just a lack of
work and so then we have financial
pressure it could just be the lack of
healthy family you know dynamics in your
home it could be just the sheer
isolation if you have really maybe no
family like in your home right so you're
there alone day after day after day
after day and I mean I can't imagine
like that just right on and amnon
there's lots of reasons this is a really
challenging time now having said that
though there is maybe to some maybe I'm
not to say all
there's there's old to say a pretty
large percentage who I am pretty
fascinated by and I've been thinking
about these folks a lot and I suspect
there are more people in this camp even
than we realize
but basically I'm fascinated by the
phenomena of those saying you know what
um
yes this has been challenging and like
stressful and difficult like all that's
true and yes I've had times of overwhelm
and we're just like I think I have at
least one for you today like not
necessarily externally to blow up but at
least if not internally or quietly in my
room um right so so having said like
acknowledging that um but still there
are those problems whether we realize
that would also agree though that this
sort of forced quarantine in ways has
actually been good like good for you
good maybe for your family dynamics or
just your your it's friendships or
family like you kind of it's been a time
of some soul-searching and there's been
some actually really good things that
have come out of it and to some degree
really I'd include myself in this group
and some of that is because I've touched
on this the last few weeks but so that's
because of my pace alright so for the
last ten years it's just been a lot at
first it was because I was finishing my
undergrad degree and then I transitioned
and working on my master's degree and
then I was planting you know my first
church and then I was planting my second
church this one the table and so on and
so forth that all that has taken ten
years and so in in the midst of that
like I was taking my Sabbath day of rest
that was what that was a message two
weeks ago and you know when we as a
family like we were okay um like it
maybe not not perfect but we were pretty
decent of having like family time and
maybe family night and Maggie my wife
and I we would go out on coffee dates
you know consistently
and I coach my kiddos soccer team so you
know that did add like a certain
busyness to our life but we still had
but we had time together right it wasn't
like since the quarantine my kids
haven't said like hey mama who's that
guy he was living at our house the past
few weeks oh oh that's your father right
we were no we weren't there but we were
a probably like many of you very very
busy busy all the time life was very
very stressful and it's it's almost like
this virus has just hit a massive pause
button and I swear we have been home
more in the last three weeks than the
last probably three months combined we
have played more family basketball in
the last three weeks than ever uh and I
was talking with Maggie about this and
she said like Brett I hate to say this
like because it has been challenging and
I know for other people it's just kind
of the worst but at least for us I kind
of feel like maybe this is like the best
thing that's happened to us in a while
now that's a whole conversation like we
need to kind of have as a family and
figure out hmm okay after this
quarantine ends what changes do we make
such that we don't have to say man good
thing that quarantine Devi's in our
houses forever so we can spend time with
one another right that sort of points to
some things we need to work through but
what that got me to thinking about and
and I think this is kind of the broader
all of us can be reflecting on this is a
word and that word is the title of my
message tonight
that word is boundaries now boundaries
is a word that has been sort of
popularized more recently by writers
like dr. Henry cloud John Townsend as
well as brené Brown a family therapist a
rabbi named Edwin Friedman and really
many other therapists psychologists even
theologians and the reason is that what
they've kind of tuned into is the fact
that learning how to set boundaries in
your life
is absolutely essential for us to be
spiritually and emotionally healthy
people all right so what what do I mean
by boundaries well here's I'm gonna give
you a few um different definitions we'll
give you two of this first one this is
I'm I've kind of drawn this from dr.
clouds work it's not a direct quote but
this is kind of the idea that boundaries
are about ownership what what problems
decisions emotions actions even
relationships am I responsible for and
not responsible for another way of
saying this is what's within the domain
of my control because I can only be
responsible for something that at least
to some degree I have some measure of
control over all right that's the first
definition here's the second one this is
from dr. Brene brown it's really is
short and succinct boundaries named
clearly what's okay and what's not okay
now you can hear in brown's emphasis um
here you can hear that here here here
it's HEA are you can hear here you get
it you can hear here her emphasis on
relationships I'm naming clearly here's
how you can treat me here's how you can
talk to me here's how you can relate and
then not right here's the boundary
marker this so it's okay this is what's
not okay and one reason I suspect that
some of us maybe more than we might
think are finding this quarantine in
sort of a strange roundabout way
somewhat helpful is because it has
forced some boundaries like into our
lives right we can't be there for
everyone we can't do everything and it's
actually brought us some sanity now the
reason I believe this is particularly
relevant in our context is because the
Christian notion of love the Christian
emphasis on Impa
and even you know like serve that serve
one another love one another is often
misunderstood to mean that we should
live bound realist lives it's it's
misinterpreted to mean that anytime
someone asks for our help the answer is
is yes and never know and not even the
more gentle not right now or not this
time right we misunderstand Christian
loves to be something that's always non
confrontational something that always
pleases people that always makes others
happy but what we don't realize is that
love isn't is not just about another's
flourishing which is to say not simply
their short-term um happiness but about
their long-term growth in maturity right
so in other words it is about it is
about their flourishing but but not just
in the short run but in the long run as
well um I remember very early in our
marriage I was I was upset with Maggie
about something and I don't remember
this is I mean we've been married quite
a while was fifteen years ago and so we
were something I was upset about
something and I started to turn to yell
started as we st. Texas I started holler
oops that's what that's like the Texas
sweet way to say eyes already yell and
I'm just kind of like yelling at Maggie
and she looked at me if she says no and
I mean talk about shutting me up like I
was just like uh and she said she said
you will not speak to me that way now my
pride was wounded but what was she doing
she was drawing a very clear boundary as
she saying here's what's okay here's
what's not okay here's how you can treat
me here's how you cannot treat me now
did she do that because you know she's a
meanie or because she just didn't really
love me no of course not she drew that
boundary
because she she actually did love me now
this brings me to a really fascinating
insight from the research of grenade
Brown where she's done a lot of research
into compassionate people and she said
that as she did this research it really
shocked her to find out that the most
compassionate and empathetic people she
met during her research these were these
were people who are just the most loving
the people with the greatest capacity to
sit with others in their pain and hear
what they feel and just love them what's
the process that those people she said
we're also the most bound read here's
exactly how she put it she said the most
compassionate people I have interviewed
were the most bound read and I've been
reflecting on this like why is that I
think this is why because love without
boundaries is a recipe for resentment
all right I will eventually feel um
trespassed upon and if I can't say no to
you then then eventually I can't say yes
right to really give an honest yes
requires that I could have said no and
but this is something this is difficult
for us because again we're good
Christian folks like we want people to
feel like we love them and this brings
me to Jesus if you think about it um
jesus was he was an incredibly loving
person but he was also quite good at
boundaries so I mean here's a sermon
I've never heard preached but I'm about
to give it to you this little mini
sermon is called the times jesus said no
so here's the fasted many of you
examples Luke chapter 4 beginning in
verse 40 the text says this at sunset
the people brought to Jesus all who had
various kinds of sickness and laying his
hands on each one he healed them
moreover demons came out of many people
shouting you are the son of God but he
rebuked them and would not allow them to
speak because they knew he was the
Messiah at daybreak Jesus went out to a
solitary place
the people were looking for him and when
they came to where he was they tried to
keep him from leaving them but he said I
must proclaim the good news of the
kingdom of God to the other towns also
because that is why I was sent verse 24
and he kept on preaching in the
synagogue's of Judea and I mean what
this is naming is that Jesus left right
there were still people there who needed
to be healed there there were still
people there who were like desperate for
his his um time his attention his
Healing Touch and yet Jesus said know
why because yes it's true that Jesus was
God in the flesh
but he was also fully human and he only
had so much energy so much capacity so
much time and you'll notice he named
that he had a broader mission to
accomplish and so I mean it may look
like oh my gosh shirt supposed to be
Jesus like you're a nice guy how could
you say no and yeah he did here's
another story and this is one from mark
chapter 5 this is what Stephen Alviso
preached on just a few weeks ago at the
table and it's the story of the
demon-possessed man you'll recall it's
it's quite a dramatic story of this man
who he lives in a graveyard he cuts
himself with stones he's incredibly
violent really kind of dangerous the
townspeople have have tried to chain him
up but in a wild-eyed rage he rips the
chains off and so I mean he's he's sort
of the epitome of like the outcast but
Jesus sees the man at a distance the man
sees him and then the text says the man
comes running like right at Jesus that
he he throws himself at Jesus feet
and then Jesus commands the demons to
come out of him
they do the man is utterly and
completely transformed like for the
first time in many years the text says
that he's he's fully in his right mind
and then Jesus begins to get into a boat
to leave we pick up a story mark chapter
5 verse 18 says as Jesus was getting
into the boat the man who had been
demon-possessed begged to go with him
so notice the man is I mean he's
emotional right that we're begged that's
you don't do that kind of coldly or
intellectually this is like I'm
envisioning a man maybe down on his
knees
perhaps with tears in his eyes he's
begging Jesus please let me go with you
and so what is people-pleaser Jesus say
well verse 19 puts it very clearly
it just says Jesus did not let him but
said go home to your own people right he
has a purpose here to your own people
tell them how much the Lord has done for
you in how he has had mercy on you again
Jesus he was loving he was compassionate
but he knew how to set boundaries he
knew how to say no here's one last
example this is short and sweet Jesus is
teaching a number of people it's like a
crowd of people when suddenly one of
them requests that Jesus help mediate a
dispute between them and their sibling
about an inheritance this is Luke
chapter 12 we start in verse 13 someone
in the crowd said to him teacher tell my
brother to divide the inheritance with
me jesus replied man who appointed me a
judge or an arbiter between you in other
words what are you doing bro like don't
triangle me into your family dispute you
need to like work your stuff out now
what fascinates me about these stories
is that in them
Jesus appears to be what we would call a
bad Christian because
we think of Christian love as being
basically being an incredibly agreeable
person I'm always saying yes never
hurting someone's feelings right never
I'm never challenging someone to grow up
but as I said earlier that's not love so
I wouldn't spend some time getting
really practical with you so I want to
shift to here are four myths about
boundaries just to kind of keep
unpacking our thinking on this
and these four myths I got from dr.
Henry cloud and dr. John Townsend their
book titled boundaries you can pick that
book up if you'd like some more in-depth
teaching on this so we give you four
myths first myth if I set boundaries I'm
being selfish right you we get this like
I mean I can imagine someone looking at
Jesus and those examples above insane
like that you are being selfish it's not
about you Jesus you know or something
that effect but the truth is with
boundaries it's actually the opposite as
we looked at in the passages like I just
named right um
Jesus ability set boundaries that was so
key and but here's how brené Brown puts
it right she said the most boundary
people are the most caring people why
because I can't give what I don't have
if I can't love others if I'm utterly
and completely depleted um like and
honestly what your family what your
company what your church needs is really
the best you which means we we want you
to set boundaries that's healthy like in
the end um we win your family wins your
marriage wins your relationships win
like it's good it's not it's the
opposite right it's not if you set
boundaries you're being selfish it's if
you don't like that's the selfish thing
okay so that's
that's first the first miss second myth
um boundaries are a sign of disobedience
so this comes from kind of messed up
communities and if I'm really honest
autumns religious circles sometimes in
those kind of communities you'll hear
something like you know a person they're
setting boundaries and they're just
they're not really on board with who we
are I'm just not really a fit they
they're just not really giving us you
know what we need
they must have like a hard heart and
again this is that's just bad theology
and bad yes that this is completely
irresponsible to think about it
because the truth is that a lack of
healthy boundaries in our lives that's
actually a sign of disobedience to God
right it's not the other way around it's
not by saying yes to everyone and
totally over sending myself that that's
like God honoring in the end right God
has given us a certain capacity a
certain you might even call it like a
circle of care and responsibility other
people called a sphere of influence and
he's called us to steward that and yet
if we spend no years uh turley depleting
ourselves with no boundaries and then in
the end we'll probably blame God and
everyone else how can they've done this
to me when actually was like our home in
the first place right like it's much
better if we just go ahead and set those
boundaries that's actually a sign of
obedience to God and that's really
what's best for our communities um third
myth if I begin setting boundaries I
will be hurt by others this isn't this
is a tough one because often we do it we
fear right if we start setting these
boundaries then oh my gosh like I spouse
will leave for my friends will abandon
me or my kids will hate me um here's how
Henry cloud in John Townsend
they say boundaries are a litmus test
for the quality of our relationships and
this this is actually a point um dealt
with a lot by rabbi and Family Therapist
Edwin Friedman he calls it he calls it
sabotage
she says often when we change we upset
the homeostasis the status quo of a
relationship and sometimes people don't
like that now the more um the most
mature people will actually be fine with
it
they might even celebrate your growth
that's what do you know you've found a
good friend um a good spouse good church
community is someone who says you know
what it's good that you're setting that
boundary however the most immature
people in your life they will not will
but they may not probably won't
celebrate you setting this boundary um
having said that even if like your
spouse or your children or friends or
whatever don't initially react well
there's a very real possibility that if
you can work through that conflict that
actually all of you will grow in your
relationship in the end will be
strengthened on the back end and you'll
grow and learn come through it alright
that's a third fourth myth if I set
boundaries I will I will harm others dr.
cloud he draws a wonderful distinction
between harm and hurt harm is about like
honestly damaging people so when we say
words tinged with like venom and hate we
can harm when we use our bodies to do
violence we can harm however sometimes
we must hurt someone's feelings in the
short term so that we they in our
relationship can actually thrive in the
long term this is this is why setting
boundaries may seem on the surface like
it's harmful um but
but actually it can be hurtful but it
but it doesn't harm on the other hand
avoiding conflict right we refusing to
set boundaries and in refusing to
challenge others that may seem really
nice but actually in the end
that just might be the most harmful
thing you can do to yourself and those
you love as you can see with boundaries
on their boundaries are all about the
long game
you know I I agree if you just want
short-term comforts um don't set
boundaries live with no boundaries this
in this moment in this conversation and
this day this week like it will almost
always be easier to just not set
boundaries but if you're playing the
long game which all of us should be
right in our relationship with Christ
with others with ourselves um that it's
so so so vitally important that we learn
to set boundaries now um all this might
sound like input for maybe like after
the season we're in you know once this
virus is over and we all return to a
more normal whatever that new normal
will look like kind of daily existence
um but but I really don't think that's
the case like this is just for some time
down the road um we really do need
boundaries today
we need to choose like healthy ways of
relating and loving and being honest
today for example um relationally you
might need to have an honest
conversation with someone that you're
relating to in like your home or family
or something where you say hey you can't
treat me like that or that no we're not
gonna speak to each other like that or
if you've maybe been caring for people
for weeks on end like in your house your
setting on whether it's kids or a friend
in need or an aging parent you might
need to say you know what I need a day
or an afternoon or an hour and in in
that time I'm sorry I cannot care for
you I overheard
a funny podcast this week from Jen
Hatmaker so Mindy my sister-in-law was
in the kitchen and she was like playing
this audio clip and I was like turned up
and it was Jen Hatmaker who apparently
had just kind of reached if y'all know
Jen she's kind of a Christian like
author writer that's the same thing no
writer um podcaster public speaker she's
she's wonderful um but she does these
podcasts and so she had been though she
has like teenagers and full house on and
she's been caring for people unendingly
many of us and so she finally had just
reached the end of it and so she like
made this podcast she said I'm sitting
in my bathroom like in my bathtub and I
have a glass of wine and the doors
locked and she's like they're shooting
this podcast
basically the podcast was oh my gosh oh
I am so done do and II done done and
what's she doing right she's setting the
boundary sounded like maybe she waited a
little too long but nonetheless she's
setting that boundary and that's a
really good thing so I'll close is a
final quote from brené Brown she's
talking about since learning about
boundaries she said I'm not as sweet as
I used to be but I am more loving and
friends at the table that's exactly who
I long for us to be like I don't want us
to be the sweetest Church around but I
do want us to strive too long to be the
most loving the most compassionate of
the most honest church that that folks
have ever interacted with because I
think that kind of church community
that's one that's learning to be like
the Lord Jesus so we go ahead and pray
with me God I I know this is one of
those topics that preaches really easy
and we can kind of nod our heads and say
like yes I so need to do that but it
becomes
incredibly challenging in the moment and
so I lift up every person listening or
watching to this message and I pray that
you would give them courage courage to
set those boundaries that they need in
their life to thrive to be healthy in
vibrant and to flourish and that you
would give them the wisdom to know how
to go about it
but they wouldn't rant and rave and
freak out and yell at people but but
that they would calmly do the thing
you're calling them to do establish the
boundaries that they need and Lord may
you through this process grow all of us
up into the fullness of the image of
your son Jesus Christ because that's our
purpose and heart and and as we do that
may we impact others in beautiful
beautiful ways so it's in the name of
Jesus Christ I pray
[Music]
melodye my dancing my wants you are
beautiful my sweet sweet song you are
beautiful my sweet sweet song I'm
singing again thanks Joe and Josh and
thanks Brett for your message please
stick around with us we're gonna keep
the live stream going a little longer
it's what's called our post service
online mixer just to help each other to
connect and discuss feel free to ask
questions Brett's gonna hang around and
just interact with you all around the
message so we'd love to have you stick
with us and for those of you that need
to head out feel free to do so let me
just send you out with this benediction
may the Lord direct your hearts into
God's love and Christ's perseverance may
you hold with both hands the grief and
uncertainty of Good Friday with the hope
and expectation of Easter Sunday and may
we enter the week ahead remembering that
we are resurrection people
be blessed and know that you are loved
and that you were enough just as you are
have a good week love you guys thank you
so gonna say goodbye to Josh and Joe too
but bye guys Oh CJ thanks dude thank you
thank you Oh Kailyn have have a safe
time working night shift oh that is rude
that's rough a night shift at a hospital
right now
you can't imagine um thanks dawn and
it's so amazing to see like all of you
wonderful people
nyeeeeehhh you're so welcome
um let's see
Maggie talking about oh yeah it has been
a long time since we've sung my opening
song it's beautiful I love dinner the
worship circle so good Gail had said I
think we often forget or just don't know
that Jesus said no thank you for that
reminder it's so true you know you know
I don't think of them kind of in yeah in
that way and it's not yet and again like
he's not being a meanie he's not he
loves the people but um he was human you
know he's human
so yeah thank you really Allah
essentially it fern requests from my the
table family that's true you do need to
get connected so this is one good thing
about its kind of seeing all the
comments is you can go back through
click a name someone's name you
recognize and then like friend them on
Facebook and yeah it is it so it's a
great way to kind of stay in the loop
and connected Chris was just saying a
message on boundaries so appropriate
with teleworking at home with a family
it's so challenging to balance yes i
growing I grew up with my dad works from
home for many years like probably most
of my junior high in high school years
and he very clearly had some boundaries
he would have like the door like he had
a sign on it like basically said like
hey shut up don't just barge in here
being loud and you know because he could
be talking with like someone don't know
some executive in India or something and
all the sudden his boys were like hey so
having said that we do have to show
grace in this time because we're all in
tight quarters you know yeah Milagros
did Jesus say no to cheesecake I need to
learn this skill yeah CJ said I've
shared my little statement with a few
people this last week in the question I
get every time is how do I protect my
peace I go to answer is to protect peace
with prayer that's beautiful that's
beautiful
yeah it's a giving kind of a constant
will be the word kind of surrender to
God you know that's so much of the
spiritual life life of God with Christ
is this constant surrender and like it's
not just about us striving hard like I'm
gonna grit my teeth and protect the
peace I have but it's this Lord I
surrender to you and I know in you I
have all peace I have all joy I have
everything I need and that coming
kind of thing so that's beautiful
Roy said I don't think he did cheesecake
is holy is it holy Nick it's so so good
to have you with us thank you for
joining us tonight
that's amazing
yes in the Brock parents awesome glad to
have you
well alright if anyone has any other
final questions or anything or final
goodbyes or hellos or anything the ink
go ahead and wrap up so cool well thank
you so much for joining us tonight and
I'm really looking forward next week
with our Good Friday service at Easter
that would be amazing amazing to be with
you all and so yeah be sure to to kind
of tune in let's see seven o'clock
Friday night 5:00 p.m. Sunday 4:00
Eastern so I will see you all then so
love you lots
love you Chris and Karen Marisa
CJ Roy all the people Nick my sweet
Maggie
Milagros yeah love you all so alright
I'll chat with you later and Oh huge
thank you to Jacob - for doing behind
the scenes tech stuff thanks Jacob
seaman
you